in the words of Theodore Roosevelt the
credit belongs to the man or woman who
is actually in the arena please join me
in welcoming Hillary Rodham Clinton
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you Wow I am so
delighted to be here sorry we're not
outside but this makes it kind of cozy I
want to thank President Saleh Vee and
Dean Chun thank you Alex a Razorback fan
from Little Rock Arkansas for getting us
started on such a high note
thanks to Alexis and Josh for your
comments and your introduction thanks to
all of the family and friends here today
for allowing me to share this happy
occasion and good afternoon to everyone
joining us by live stream from around
campus but most of all congratulations
to the class of 2018 I am thrilled for
all of you even the three of you who
live in Michigan and didn't request your
absentee ballots in time
what
before before I go any further I just
want to be sure did the students from
the new colleges make it here I worried
that your flights might be delayed sorry
Franklin and Paulie Marie I heard you at
a great first year and I am honored that
this class has invited me to be your
speaker now I see looking out at you
that you are following the tradition of
over the top hats so I brought a hat - a
[Applause]
Russian hat
[Applause]
I mean if you can't beat them join them
now being here with you brings back a
flood of memories I remember the first
time I arrived on campus as an incoming
law student in the fall of 1969 wearing
my bell-bottoms driving a beat-up old
car with a mattress tied to the roof I
had no idea what to expect and now to be
honest I had had some trouble making up
my mind between Yale and Harvard Law
School's then one day while we were
still in that period of decision making
I was invited to a cocktail party at
Harvard for potentially incoming law
students where I met a famous law
professor a friend of mine a male law
student introduced me to this famous law
professor I mean truly big three-piece
suit watch-chain and my friend said
professor this is Hillary Rodham she's
trying to decide whether to come here
next year or sign up with our closest
competitor now the great man gave me a
cool dismissive look and said well first
of all we don't have any close
competitors
and secondly we don't need any more
women at Harvard
now I was leaning toward Yale anyway but
that pretty much sealed the deal and
when I came to Yale I was one of 27
women out of 235 law students it was the
first year women were admitted to the
College and as that first class of women
prepared to graduate four years later
the New York Times reported on Yale's
foray into co-education noting that the
women quote worked harder and got
somewhat better grades than the 940 men
graduating with them a fact they went on
to say that some of the men apparently
found threatening well I was shocked
but over the years Yale has been a home
away from home for me a place I've
returned to time and again I spoke to
class day back in 2001 on the 300th
anniversary of the University and I hope
that that will be the case for many of
you as well this school has been
responsible for some of my most
treasured friends and colleagues people
like Jake Sullivan and Harold Koh and
I've watched some of you grow up like
Rebecca Shaw who's graduating today and
you'll hear from shortly and I've been
honored to serve over the last year or
two working with some of the Yale Law
School faculty including the new dean
Heather gherkin
now Yale grads many of whom are also
here today have worked for me in the
United States Senate the State
Department on my presidential campaigns
and I have been so well served I have a
very dedicated campaign intern here
graduating David Shimer the class of
2018
but I have to confess of all the
formative experiences I had at Yale
perhaps none was more significant than
the day during my second year when I was
cutting through what was then the
student lounge with some friends and I
saw this tall handsome guy with a beard
who looked like a Viking I said to my
friend well who is that and she said
well that's Bill Clinton he's from
Arkansas and that's all he ever talks
about and then as if on cue I hear him
saying and not only that we grow the
biggest watermelons in the world and I
was like who is this person but you know
he kept looking at me and I kept looking
back and so we were in the wall library
one night I was studying but I couldn't
help but see occasionally as I lifted my
head up um that he was again looking at
me so finally I thought this is
ridiculous
so I got up went over to him and I said
you're gonna keep looking at me and I'm
gonna keep looking back we at least
ought to be introduced I'm Hillary
Rodham who are you and that started a
conversation that continues to this day
now it was also here at Yale that I saw
a flier in the law school on a bulletin
board that changed my life now some of
your parents and grandparents may
remember flyers and bulletin boards for
the rest of you suffice it to say that
was how we got information it was like
Facebook but the bulletin board didn't
steal your personal information
[Applause]
so one day I saw a note about a woman
named Marian Wright Edelman at Yale Law
School graduate civil rights activist
who would go on to found the Children's
Defense Fund Marian was coming back to
campus to give a lecture I went I was
captivated to hear her talk about using
her Yale education to create a headstart
program in rural Mississippi and I wound
up working for her that summer and the
experienced opened my eyes to the ways
that the law can protect children or
come up short because like many of you I
learned just as much outside the four
walls of the classroom as I did sitting
in a lecture hall and I discovered a
passion that has animated my life and my
work ever since now a lot has changed
since I was here in 2019 Yale will
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
matriculation of women at the college
and the 150th anniversary of the first
women graduate students at Yale and I
heard that Yale officially changed the
term freshmen to first-year I also heard
amazingly that the Dukes men and the
Whiffenpoofs have started welcoming
women now as for my long lost
wyff's audition tape I have buried it so
deep not even WikiLeaks will be able to
find it
because if you thought my emails were
scandalous you should hear my singing
voice
[Music]
I find it very exciting that today's
graduates hail from all 50 states the
District of Columbia Puerto Rico Guam
and 56 other countries and in your four
years on campus you've survived late
nights and the best cubicles and early
mornings and the Sterling stacks you've
trekked up Science Hill maybe you've
even found love at the Last Chance dance
and now you're ready to take on your
next adventure but maybe some of you are
reluctant to leave I understand that
it's possible to feel both because the
class of 2018 is graduating at one of
the most tumultuous times in the history
of our country and I say that as someone
who graduated in the 60s I recently went
back and looked up those famous lines
from Charles Dickens in A Tale of Two
Cities because you know I usually end
after saying it was the best of times it
was the worst of times
but it goes on it was the age of wisdom
it was the age of foolishness it was the
epoch of belief it was the epoch of
incredulity it was the season of light
it was the season of darkness it was the
spring of hope it was the winter of
despair
now Dickens was writing about the years
leading up to the French Revolution but
he could have been describing the
ricocheting highs and lows of this
moment in America we're living through a
time when fundamental rights civic
virtue freedom of the press even facts
and reason are under assault like never
before but we are also witnessing an era
of new moral conviction civic engagement
and a sense of devotion to our democracy
and country so here's the good news if
any group were ever prepared to rise to
the occasion it is you the class of 2018
you've already demonstrated the
character and courage that will help you
navigate this tumultuous moment and most
of all you've demonstrated resilience
now that's a word that's been on my mind
a lot recently one of my personal heroes
Eleanor Roosevelt said you gain strength
courage and confidence by every
experience in which you really stop to
look fear in the face you are able to
say to yourself I have lived through
this or I can take the next thing that
comes along
well that's resilience and it's so
important because everyone everyone gets
knocked down what matters is whether you
get back up and keep going
this may be hard for a group of yale
soon-to-be graduates to accept but yes
you will make mistakes in life you will
even fail it happens to all of us
no matter how qualified or capable we
are take it from me oh I remember those
first months after that 2016 election
were not easy we all had our own methods
of coping I went for long walks in the
woods
Yale students went for long walks in
East Rock Park I spent hours going down
a Twitter rabbit hole you spent hours in
the Yale memes group I had my fair share
of Chardonnay you had penny drinks at
woods
I practice yoga and alternate nostril
breathing
you took psych and the good life and let
me just get this out of the way no I'm
not over it I still think about the 2016
election I still regret the mistakes I
made
I still think though that understanding
what happened in such a weird and wild
election in American history will help
us defend our democracy in the future
with your right left center Republican
Democrat independent vegetarian whatever
we all have a stake in that so today as
a person I'm okay but as an American I'm
concerned you know personal resilience
is important but it's not the only form
of resilience we need right now we also
need community resilience that's
something that this class has embodied
during your time on campus literally at
times like in the march of resilience
your sophomore year it was the biggest
demonstration
the biggest demonstration in the history
of the school that's 300 plus years led
by women of color supported by students
and faculty determined to make Yale a
more just equitable and safe place for
everyone many of you have said that
March was a defining moment in your
college experience and that says
something about this class and your
values because the truth is our country
is more polarized than ever we have
sorted ourselves in two opposing camps
and that divides how we see the world
the data backs this up there are more
liberals and conservatives than there
used to be and fewer centrists our
political parties are more ideologically
and geographically consistent which
means there are fewer northern
Republicans and fewer Southern Democrats
and the divides on race and religion are
starker than ever before and as the
middle shrink partisan animosity grooved
now I'm not going to get political here
but this isn't simply a both sides
problem the radicalization of American
politics hasn't been symmetrical there
are leaders in our country who blatantly
incite people with hateful rhetoric who
fear change who see the world in
zero-sum terms so that if others are
gaining well they must be losing that's
a recipe for polarization and conflict
our social fabric is fraying and the
bonds of community that hold us together
are fractured this isn't just a problem
because it leads to unpleasant
conversations over the Thanksgiving
dinner table it's a problem because it
undermines the Civic spirit that makes
democracy possible the habits of the
heart that de Tocqueville found so
unique in the American character I
believe healing our country is going to
take what I call radical empathy
as hard as it is this is a moment to
reach across divides of race class and
politics to try to see the world through
the eyes of people very different from
ourselves and to return to rational
debate to find a way to disagree without
being disagreeable to try to recapture a
sense of community and common humanity
when we think about politics and judge
our leaders we can't just ask am I
better off than I was two years or four
years ago we have to ask are we all
better off are we as a country better
stronger and fairer that's something
you've done here at Yale you've learned
that you don't need to be an immigrant
to be outraged when a classmate's father
a human being who contributes to his
family and his country is unjustly
deported you don't need to be a person
of color to understand that when black
students feel singled out and targeted
we still have work to do and you don't
need to experience gun violence to know
that when a teenager in Texas who just
survived a mass shooting says she's not
surprised by what happened at her school
because and I quote I've always felt
like eventually it was going to happen
here too
we are failing our children so enough is
enough we need to come together and we
certainly need common-sense gun safety
legislation as soon as we can get it
now
empathy should not only be at the center
of our individual lives our families and
our communities it should be at the
center of our public life our policies
and our politics I know we don't always
think of politics and empathy as going
hand-in-hand but they can and more than
that they must as former secretary
Madeleine Albright writes and her
terrific new book fascism a warning
she says this generosity of spirit this
caring about others and about the
proposition that we are all created
equal is the single most effective
antidote to the self-centered moral
numbness that allows fascism to thrive
and of course Madeleine had personal
experience fleeing the Nazis in
Czechoslovakia as a baby returning after
the war fleeing the Communists as a
young girl now that brings me to one
more form of resilience that's been on
my mind over the last year Democratic
resilience in 1787 after the
Constitutional Convention in
Philadelphia Benjamin Franklin who by
the way received an honorary degree from
Yale was asked by a woman in the street
outside Independence Hall well doctor
what have we got a republic or a
monarchy and Franklin answered a
republic if you can keep it right now
we're living through a full-fledged
crisis in our democracy now there are
not tanks in the streets but what's
happening right now goes to the heart of
who we are as a nation and I say this
not as a Democrat who lost an election
but as an American afraid of losing a
country there are certain things that
are so essential they should transcend
politics waging a war on the rule of law
and a free press delusion amaizing
elections perpetrating shameless
corruption and rejecting the
dia that our leaders should be public
servants undermines our national unity
and attacking truth and reason evidence
and facts should alarm us all you and
your parents have just paid for a
first-class world-class education and as
Yale history professor Timothy Snyder
writes in his book on tyranny to abandon
facts is to abandon freedom if nothing
is true then no one can criticize power
because there is no basis upon which to
do so if nothing is true then all is
spectacle I think professor Schneider
both in that book and in his new one the
road to unfreedom is sounding the alarm
as loudly as he can because attempting
to erase the line between fact and
fiction truth and reality is a core
feature of authoritarianism the goal is
to make us question logic and reason and
to sow mistrust toward exactly the
people we need to rely on our leaders
the press experts who seek to guide
public policy baked-on based on evidence
even ourselves just this week former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said if
our leaders seek to conceal the truth or
we as people become accepting of
alternative realities that are no longer
grounded in facts then we as American
citizens are on a pathway to relinquish
Itali but he's absolutely right
so how do we build democratic resilience
I think it starts with standing up for
truth facts and reason not just in the
classroom and on campus but every day in
our lives it means speaking out about
the vital role of higher education in
our society to create opportunity and
equality it means calling out actual
fake news when we see it and supporting
brave journalists and their reporting
maybe even by subscribing to a newspaper
now most of all as obvious as it seems
it means voting in every election not
just at the presidential ones so yes
these are challenging times for America
but we've come through challenging times
before you know I think back to the
night Barack Obama was elected president
many of us so many of us were jubilant
even I who had once hoped to beat him
was estatic it was such a hopeful moment
and yet in some ways this moment feels
even more hopeful because this is a
battle-hardened hope tempered by loss
and clear-eyed about the stakes we are
standing up to policies that hurt people
we are standing up for all people being
treated with dignity we are doing the
work to translate those feelings into
action and the fact that some days it is
really hard to keep at it just makes it
that much more remarkable that so many
of us are in fact keeping at it it's not
easy to wade back into the fight every
day but we're doing it and that's why I
am optimistic because of how
unbelievably tough Americans are proving
to be I've encountered lots of people in
recent months who give me hope the
Parkland students who endured
unthinkable tragedy and have responded
with courage and resolve the leaders and
groups I've gotten to know through
outward together an organization I
started after the election to encourage
the outpouring of grassroots engagement
that we're seeing everyone who is
marching registering voters and diving
into the issues facing us like never
before some for the very first time in
their lives and I find hope in the wave
of women running for office and winning
and hope in the women and men who are
dismantling the notion that women should
have to endure harassment and violence
as a part of our lives so we have a long
way to go there are many fights to fight
and more seem to rise every day
it will take work to keep up the
pressure to stay vigilant
- neither close our eyes nor numb our
hearts or throw up our hands and say
someone else take over from here
because at this moment in our history
our country depends on every citizen
believing in the power of their actions
even when that power is invisible and
their efforts feel like an uphill battle
of every citizen voting in every
election even when your side loses it is
a matter of infinite faith this faith we
have in the ability to govern ourselves
to come together to make honourable
practical compromise in the pursuit of
ends that will lift us all up and move
us forward so yes we need to pace
ourselves but also lean on each other
look for the good wherever we can
celebrate heroes and courage children
find ways to disagree respectfully we
need to be ready to lose some fights
because we will as John McCain recently
reminded us no Just Cause is futile even
if it's lost what matters what matters
is to keep going no matter what
keep going the Yale your graduating from
is very different from the Yale I
graduated from it's different even from
the Yale that welcomed you four years
ago four years ago not one of Yale's
colleges was named after a woman today's
students are carrying on the legacy of a
trailblazing LGBT civil rights activist
at Pauli Murray College and celebrating
one of Yale's own hidden figures at
Grace Hopper college named after the
naval officer who happened to be one of
the first computer programmers in
America those changes didn't happen on
their own
you made them possible you kept fighting
you kept the faith and because of that
in the end you changed Yale as much as
Yale changed you and now it's time
for you to make your mark on the world I
know the best the best for you for Yale
and for America is yet to come and you
each will have a role to play and a
contribution to make thank you and
congratulations to the class of 2018
[Applause]
[Music]